all of us we have to fear for
ourselves all of us no one is
sa used to
say the heart in between of the fingers
of Allah the way his majesty Allah when
we say fingers Allah not like any human
beings or any creation all right Allah
changes it the way he wishes and unnown
I would I advise you there is series of
people used to be with Isis with who
were from the Western World they become
openly and what have notice apostasy is
very known among why told us about
them they will leave Islam just as the
arrow leave the the bow and this exactly
look when I see this person I
say when he saw the individual that
Prophet Muhammad explained to him that
you'll be fighting against this group of
and the leader one of them he will have
a problem with his with his hands okay
when he saw that he
said the truth and he never lied
look at this he used to call us he used
to call us we are working for the
government he used to say that
we you
know there was a guy who was very close
to he was from Denmark he became he went
Somalia Kenya you know same thing this
guy who call then he become
may Allah save us you know you know you
you should be my friend you know why cuz
you you make my height feel good know
than you you
know what's your name Jude Jude Jude
Jude judee Jud Judah not Judah Judah you
Judah
you
no yeah go ahead so wait wait okay I
maybe you guys heard all this all I've
asked it several times right um but I
want ask you a question in regards to um
Quran 3:55 I want to know if it's a a
past tense or is it a future event we as
a Muslim that's a beauty why the Quran
is been preserved because we don't
memorize numbers and we don't know what
is in text that's why you lost text and
numbers no the verse the chapter we can
discuss read you read
Arabic you do hoodoo or whatever you got
to
was chapter 3 verse
chapter 3: 55 chapter 3 verse 50 55 55
yes
please I'm going to get the
English 55 55 I want to know is that a
let me read it first I'm going to tell
you I'm going to pass my judgment if I
Haven I want to know if it's a past
tense or is it when I read it I will let
you or a future event you can hear you
can and then I want to go to another
verse after no no before you go to
another verse say after have to ask
question I have a question as well okay
go ahead
okay this one 355 is that it chapter 3
the English one to see the one well this
the what you call the translation
so aldah for
islamd Jesus Christ is Lord was he God
Jesus yes he says it in Aramaic he said
what uh I am the Living God that's go
know everything all the time uh you can
go back to to that verse too um he's son
though he's explain him as a son so he's
not God anymore he become son he was God
he was a god second ago but want to ask
him a question does he know everything
wait did Jesus say did Jesus Jesus say I
am the father are one to show you to
show you Jesus say I am with this come
to this I am the father are one the
father is great than I deal with
it 35 okay the one I'm reading is
55 yeah what is it saying as for those
who disbelieve I will give them severe
Punishment No No 355 and Jesus 3
okay no that's not 55 yeah it is 55
355 55
555 you have juice juice but it's not
this it's 54 he have you have juice this
is wrong wrong
not juice juice see is confused what am
I I'm asking 355 but trth between I
don't know chapter 3 yeah yeah you're
right that's what I'm saying 355 what
you
talking yeah 355 that's what I'm asking
about can you explain yeah English okay
yeah this is what you guys are giving
out here no the English one is uh
okay oh Jesus Son of Mary you said to
people take me and my mother go beside
Allah no that's what I'm talking about
355 chapter 3 it says in Jesus indeed I
taken raised to myself 355 sorry I'm
reading this
ver okay okay yeah yeah
yeah which
one he's showing you juice juice three
this is not chap three what is what
chapter is it what chapter is it then
okay hold this hold this hold this is
the book yall giv out what chapter is it
I don't know this one it's chapter 3
this giv out chapter 3 chapter 3 yes yes
this is chapter 3 okay verse 55 brother
that's a Beau
Islam all me tell you what the of Islam
which one is it bro this is the Quran
what is it this translation of the
meaning of the Quran this the Quran
that's why can you go to 355 pleasee I
will go I'll show you I will go the
Quran this is the Quran Quan have
yourday I can't go on my
phone please told
me yeah I don't know he's by the
way you going to your
phone 55 why is it so difficult to find
depends on on 355 oh yeah exactly that's
what I'm asking it's right here yeah can
you find that right here in this book
for me please this 55 here yes 55
55 that's it's supposed to be right here
that's supposed to be 55 right or is it
the ver is it this
verse
okay 54 54 is it 54 is it 54 or 55
here's 55 yes here's 5 let me teach you
about numbers okay and numbers sometimes
depends on because the Quran was not red
with numbers so numbers Sometimes some
some Scholars they hold two verse as one
verse just go to there's no problem go
to what I mean
so it says it says okay it says and
Allah said oh Jesus indeed I will take
you get that 54 yeah okay 54 yeah even
though it says 55 here
and okay I'm explain to you okay go
ahead I think this one is wor correct no
oh yeah it
wor it's wor we know that wor they have
different numbers that's why I told you
the beauty of Quran we keep text we
don't pay attention to numbers but
sometimes you keep one verse why you
have numbers there they do it to make it
easy for people oh okay okay so like
some people sometimes they I have they
have numbers on it too as well are you
going to tell me what you want to talk
about yes I've been asking I've been
asking so yeah what do you want to know
okay um 355 you can read it read it to
them in Arabic or whatever
okay what does it say in there so this
verse Allah said oh Jesus Son of Mary
okay don't say oh Jesus I will cause you
to sleep and raise you up to me S yeah
yeah me the translation me sleep sleep
or I will cause you to die cuz I have I
have another Muslim here who gave me a
translation from Arabic and it says I
will cause you to die they say it can
mean different things in the Quran has
two meaning even death the prop Muhammad
Ali wasallam called sleeping the cousin
of death okay okay you have to let me
finish I haven't finished sorry sorry
bro sorry sorry sorry you have to let me
finish I haven't my question yet though
you just ask a question no I didn't is
it sleep or death no in regards in
regards death giv you context okay okay
cool cool ahead sorry sorry sorry sorry
go ahead go ahead go ahead go ahead okay
so in this context it means sleep it
mean right yes Allah mentioned that they
never killed him or crucified him but
Allah saved him and raised him up to
himself all right so as mentioned that
sleeps sleep is a cous of death so you
can refer to as a death but as a Min
death
however it's Allah that caus people to
die when they sleeping those Allah have
not decreed yet for them to have a major
death will give their souls back to them
okay so you understand what mean sleep
right question is um is this in the past
or is this in the
future speaking not to him now speak to
directly no no this this verse when when
future he speaking to now this is so
this is already happened when he was
speaking to Jesus wait wait in this
verse is it is it is it a past event
already happed it already happened when
did he cause him to sleep when they
tried to crucify him Allah raised him up
when exactly and you know you know that
shows you another uh Miracle of the
language Arabic language you know the
Arabs if they
not I'm going to give it back to you I'm
just so you know the the the Quran
sometimes speaks like something is going
to happen in the future even happen in
the past the Arabs do that to cat the
people's attention Subhan Allah that's
Arabic no no it's called look who
speaking Theus the one who believe God
become baby he's talking about confusion
I mean well you the last say what it's
confusing it says Allah blew his Spirit
into no no please stop Mis the Quran
anyway that's what it says though no no
no no
it the angel okay the through the Ang
you look look you're jumping I'm no
you're jumping so anyway so this verse
it callus him to sleep now let us go
back to Jesus to be
God
yes either
sometimes so this happened in the past
in the ask you so wait I just want to
finish this question so you're saying it
happened in the past my question is when
did this happen in the past exactly it
happened on Sunday the 25th of December
5:00 in the morning are you taking a
make brother are you I mean it happened
when Jesus was about to be killed when
you betrayed him Judah betrayed him when
Judah tried to betray him so Allah
mentioned to Jesus that Allah will save
him and raise him up to cause him to
sleep and to raise him up to himself so
this happened already okay it happened
already already but nobody knows exactly
when that happened he wants the time
the cuz s said the same thing oh it
happened right before they killed him
but there was many times they tried to
kill him okay but wait when Jesus said
to when when the woman touched Jesus
said who touched me when this happen the
exact day day yeah I don't know the
exact day so well see the hypocrit I'm
saying to ask you question
why we have to know
the's come on man because the thing is
that because the reason why I ask that
because it goes with uh I think Surah 4
uh 171 where it says that um it appeared
as though so if it appeared as though
somebody was on the cross who was on the
cross you don't know you say Jesus was
already taken so when was he taken yeah
take up to the heaven Allah when exactly
that's what I'm
saying you know even the Bible in the
Bible Hebrew 57 you know it proves our
belief about Jesus was not crucified in
Hebrews 5:7 do you know what he says in
Hebrew 57 no not exactly okay so that's
you know I have many I have I out pull
it out I have asked many many Christians
even learned Christians they don't know
what it says in Hebrew 57 you know
Hebrew 57 he says something very very
interesting what he says says that Jesus
on his last day upon the Earth he prayed
to go to save him from death and Jesus
Was Heard because of his reverence he
what does it mean he was heard he was
heard mean God saved him yes because God
hears you regardless if you are a pi or
evil
doer sorry
SRE I'm from North
Africa quick
so so here God hears you regardless if
you are a good person or evil person so
why does he say in Hebrew 5:7 that God
heard the prayer of Jesus because he was
and he mentioned the reason because he
was a righteous or because he was a
reverent person mean that God saved him
because Jesus praying to be saved from
the death the Christians would try to
come back by saying no it means that he
would die
but God will bring him back to life so
therefore God never answered his prayer
for saving him from Death because still
he did die so anyway Hebrew 57 I know
you never heard it your never told you
about it can I read Because cuz you just
quoted something and try to to tell
these brothers that he was saved from
Death can I read can I read the can I
read the whole thing the whole Bible but
no not the whole thing the verse cuz you
only want to read um verse number seven
the whole ch I'm I don't have to read I
can just read that this this one part
right here okay it says in it says who
in the days of his flesh when he had
offered up um prayers and supplication
with um verant cries and tears to him to
him which is God who who was able to
save him from death and and has heard
because of his Godly fear though he was
a son right yet he learned obedience by
the by the things which he suffered and
having been persecuted he became the
author of Eternal salvation to all who
obey him okay so there's contradiction
here bro you just quoted that he was
saved and now you're saying his of
course you know already don't be
dishonest you know already that we know
we believe as a Muslim there's many Con
in the Bible and I you Pro it right now
in front of me because if he was
persecuted and he was sa from Death
illogical iral doesn't make sense that
you the one that made that up no but no
but is you just said he
was repeat again repeat again let's read
it again step by step step by step yes
read again you hear his interpretation
his interpretation is the word he was
heard and he was saved from what that's
not what it say no that's not what it
says let's read it again read it again
okay let's read it again it says who in
the days of his flesh when he had
offered up his prayer pray so he prayed
for what okay um in supplication which
verit cries in tears to him who was able
to save him from Death okay so he's was
able to
save pray to save him from Death he's
praying and he was watching you just
said earlier that this this scripture
says that he was saved yes yes but he
say he was praying to be saved the
scripture says he was praying to be
saved and he hear him did God hear him
we did the verse after say no no no no
no wait before after let me read cuz
you're playing around you're playing
around here King James versioning I can
go to B Hub and get all other no problem
no problem who in the days of his flesh
yes when he had offered prayers and
supplication he praying so he's praying
remember God is praying yes supplication
V come on
stop show Arabic language please
embarrass yourself please please don't
repeat we get off y'all won't let me
speak I see how it is it's 20 against
one I get it there's no Christian
channels here by the way but go ahead go
ahead go ahead read it he's praying he
wasn't saved he was praying to be saved
so listen to this yeah it he was praying
to be saved he wasn't Sav he just told
us we are bullying him or something but
he's bullying us he last one of me here
there's like I don't know 20 of y'all
yeah you're our guest we're going to
take care of you don't worry thank you
thank you really you become really
really don't lie don't lie on the I'm
I'm going to read the scripture show you
so he wasn't saved here he was praying
to be saved why it doesn't allow me to
finish read it go ahead I know you're
scared no you're scared cuz you know you
know you got CAU I'm trying to read it
and you're not allowing you're saying
that he was saved I'm going to read it
show show me where he was go he's
praying Okay who in the days of his
flesh who when he had offer when he had
offered prayers and supplication with v
and cries and tears to him who was able
to save him who able to save him from
Death from Death was able to save him
who was able to save him from so he's
praying to God to save him from Death
wait who able to say who a he's praying
to who was able to save him from Death
so did God save him or not no he didn't
so he was able oh my goodness he's
praying to him said he was able to save
him from Death so what he sa so was he
able or not because here says he was
able to save him from Death yes so God
is able to save him save him from Death
he was God is able to save him from
Death so he's praying to God who is able
to save him from Death is that correct
wait wait is that correct is God is he
praying to God save him from Death he's
praying to God to save him from Death to
save him from Death look I get the
English one you said you said earlier he
said God saved her from Death look look
in the Bible you said earlier that God
saved her from Death we're going to get
you the King James one you said this is
King James no no no no no no this is not
new Prince this is New King James the
1611 this is New King James bro right
here in front of new King James new King
James okay I'm going to show you King
James which is shows you that he said he
was able to save him for death because
of his reverence okay but look how you
said you twist the word you said earlier
this verse says that he was save from
because I have the Bible at and he says
that as but here look how they changed
it man this guy man this guy bro Hebrew
57 you said that this verse says that he
was saved yes he was able to save him
from Death he's able to save him but he
wasn't saved here they said the reason
because of his rence he was praying to
God to save him but are you going to
allow me to get the c or not go ahead
gohe I know he's hurting you you're
hurting yourself you're hurting yourself
he's hurting himself listen listen this
guy said ear
that that this verse Hebrews 5 verse
number 7 says that God saved him here
this verse is is is Jesus praying to God
oh listen listen listen to this listen
to this listen to this the big smack is
coming on him all this fake one even the
other are fake one listen to
this the Bible read it and knew play
with words because called New King James
fake fake can you tell us why differ
between the King James and new King
James what's the difference between the
King James and the new one there's a
yeah edit edit see edit they have to
update I don't know is a is a Bible or
iPhone always have to update it okay
okay I don't understand okay so what's
the difference between what's the
difference between this Quran and this
Quran which Quran this was the Quran
this was the Quran aepic Quran now so
why you giving it out then okay this one
to make
why y giving it out come on this called
the translation of the of the Quran oh
so this is a translation of the Hebrew
and Aramaic but I get aric I get the
Aramaic keep screaming sorry sorry I'm
very loud you know even me I'm loud but
keep Cil discussion to show you that
your the reason my dear brothers and
sisters ladies and gentlemen the reason
he put out new King James it makes sense
now because the one I have is a King
James 1611 which L says I'm just I'm
going to read to you now watch this I
can watch this that's why they have I'm
B just this is the
new this is trans translations
translation of what the speak on my no
translation the
Arabic my bad my bad my bad this Thea
that's why Quran is been preserved
because we don't follow English
translation because the English
translation the translator is not
perfect so how do you know if there's
mistakes or not we go to the Arabic
Quran because is the original one so
this called the translation of the
meaning of the Quran okay here we go
what is the Bible all right the Bible is
iphone
update always updat jokes bro okay here
it says yeah all right I got all the
translations here in the days okay this
one I have to read it I also have the
Aramaic as well in the days when he was
in In the Flesh he offered prayers and
supplication with the loud cries and and
tears to the one who able to save him
from death and he was heard because of
his reverence heard here means god
responded to him what he responded to
him to save him from what from Death is
clear that's you're lying bro because
read after no no don't run away don't
run away don't run away I have I have
aric I have aric translated English look
I have aric anv look anv now me right no
because you say I lied I'm not lying
you're is lying then because why to make
it clear to you let me make understand
when I said you want let me speak can I
speak after no you can speak after of
course you can speak same time just just
don't cut in pieces no no brother
they're going to put it the way it is I
mean you should be embarrassed to say
put it the way it is they're going to
cut in p i mean anyway listen to this
they should how you doing uncle how you
doing uncle nice to see you
UNC Christian Muslim my goodness we're
having a discussion won't let me listen
to this there's only one Christian here
though yeah yeah no problem I mean you
read it from you read it from the new
you read it from the King James can I
read it can I read it can I read it from
the Aramaic if you listen you talk you
be Muslim cuz you talk too much that's
why you I guess you're not listening
either cuz you should be a Christian
you're supposed to follow
es what I'm saying to you uh I'm saying
uh I'm going to read that same for us to
understand the passage very clear does
God hear
everyone yes God hears you if you are
evil you are even Hitler God hears him
when he speaks so when God said he heard
him because of his reverence so the hear
and here what it means he responded to
his prayer mean he accepted his prayer
therefore he saved him so let us read it
during the days of jesus' life on Earth
he offered the prayers and petition with
fervent cries and tears to the one who
could save him from Death from the one
who save him from listen the context I'm
going to finish it and he was heard
because of his irent submission what
does it mean he was heard
because of his reverence because we know
God always respond to the righteous ones
always save the rightous on so the p is
clear God Saves him according to the
Bible but the next passage contradict
the the the previous passage now if you
bring something else
you I want to I want to I want to I want
to AR lie to
us
okay I don't I don't speak I got
translation how can you I don't believe
that has that this is Bible the same do
you believe that what you English this
is English as
well this English as well arama look
look arama this is translated from
Aramaic to English be just be just
between us wa wa hold on are you are you
saying I Quran that was translated from
Arabic to English listen to my point
yeah if we have translators like for
example he's going to pull up
translation claiming AR Go and guess
this translation even though they claim
they got it from AR too who I should
trust this then wait should I
not yeah so we have both translations I
should not trust this sorry sorry stop
putting the Quran because you keep
putting the Quran he like stop it
brother listen listen carefully to my
argument what I'm saying this
translation is a Christian translation
by Christian Scholars the other
translation is going to pull out by
Christian Scholars both of them claim to
have from where from AR if his
translation go against my translation
who's going to do
determine to us which one is valid
that'll be according to you then that's
what I'm
saying so it's objective then no problem
he can read it but it makes sense now
when he says you understand the point
alhamdulillah so I did not lie he
accused me of lying I didn't know Li
aldah yes you did you said come on man
honest go back look I to be patient with
you you you're not being honest bro you
said you said that this verse is that he
was saved and then now
this my can I can I
speak I speak go ahead can I speak you
said earlier right that the Bible says
that Jesus was saved from death and then
I asked you to read the passage after
you said the passage after contradicts
the passage before yes so was he saved
or was he not saved you asking ask can
describe crack at me they say he was
saved and they say he was not saved how
are you asking me you know the
Christians here you know Christian the
he was pray heard his prayer God heard
his prayer but he wasn't what mean heard
his prayer what do you mean heard his
prayer this the same if I'm praying to
the father right now he can hear my
prayer no it's not same because I tell
you why it's good to ask question he
said because he heard his prayer because
it's already tell us because of his
reverence doesn't have to be when God
says I heard so and so prayer because of
his reverence mean I accept his pray
because he was a righteous man like the
story
ofus John the story of
God heard his prayer save him from the
whale why because he was a righteous man
so clearly heard him me he responded to
his Prayer by saving him from death and
you know what I'm going to be honest
with you I to many Christians they told
me yes he was save from Death however
later on but this guy to reject
completely so even some Christians yeah
to reject completely how am I rejecting
some CHR Christians say yes sa no he's
praying here we're not going to agree
with this can we move our we not clearly
we're not we wasting time okay you
repeting yourself you you don't I I can
show you where can't show me I showed
you already you show I show you you said
that this verse says that he was saved I
read the clearly it doesn't say that he
was you said that Jesus was saved here
anyway let us let us move on from the
topic cuz why you moving because I'm
reading your own Bible said he was saved
he was heard because of his reverence
mean God responded to his prayer that's
what it means that's what it means you
like it or not and I spoke to some
Christians they did agree with me
however their comeb back was it was safe
after me he died then God brought him
back to life so even some Christians do
accept the passage mean he was God
responded by saving him from Death so
let us move on to another topic about
Jesus to be God okay okay cool cool cool
you have a sound intellect no no no no I
have
aound
talking me you ask me about does Jesus
say to be God right you as me you ask me
do Jesus to be God
anyway
[Music]
so all right we have many
translations you ask me about Jesus
claiming to be God we have ever started
the debate let start the
discussion before you show me start
discussion okay let's lay down
Foundation First all right okay the
foundation that you and I you going to
agree with and tell me if
that God is perfect all the
time byebye take care of you I said yeah
you say yes we already agree on that no
but I want to make sure people can hear
let's not do the install so you guys can
you know cut and this video yes God is
perfect okay all the time perfect in his
knowledge yes perfect in his power yeah
all the time okay so now when you claim
that Jesus to be God and you can see he
not perfect
okay we're going to analyze that and we
see clearly that Jesus oh yeah come come
come come because they're going to cut
and past their videos we Jesus said in
Mark
13:32 can you get Mark 1332 I go it but
I want to go back to this verse as well
no no you have to go to the I'm going to
okay
Mark can you speak to your
sister is I have no control over her
Christianity by the
way that's Christianity beh or not in
certain aspect yes or no I I I yell
people don't like him no no no no that's
Christianity reuke his behavior re his
behavior that's her way of preaching no
I'm not asking his way Christianity
teaching Jesus approve his
behavior Pro
womany against Jesus lying youy against
Jesus the mother of Jesus going around
doing this the
mother what she was
doing being righteous being good woman
not mixing with she says hat preing ha
preaching haing this person cor you can
say anything this woman even herself is
she
hates you know 14 14 what no no Mark
1332 I mean it's funny that I know even
I tell the passage Jesus asked about the
day and the hour said no one knows the
day and the hour but even the in the
heaven the nor the Sun so is he the son
is he also the son he said himself nor
the son so is he the son have he's son
of no no no because I can explain do you
believe he's a Son of God I can explain
the meaning of the word son historically
speaking I can have no problem to
explain it to you okay but he says the
okay firstly I can explain to you the
meaning of the son is he speaking when
he's used by the Israelites and so on
but what you did you digress from the
main point so Jesus said that no one
knows the day and the hour even the
angels in the Heaven nor the son but
only who but God Almighty no he didn't
say that you li only the father oh you
believe that wait hold on hold on so for
you to say that do you believe in God is
a father that's what I believe or not
I'm hold on you using my scripture
youing exactly you don't even understand
what he's saying there how it's it
clearit you're using my scripture to try
to Define is a clearcut is you first you
have to believe that he's the son no I
don't have to then why you use my
scripture then when you use my scripture
that Jesus is I'm asking you what wa
watch let me show you wait your own
scripture says he's God let me show you
let me show you he's the word of Allah
okay let me show you something
the is Allah is God what nonsense
this it's an attribute differ between
attribute and so hold on so he AAL don't
digress you're digressing bro stop using
these type of words so so see I'm going
to speak let's go back anyway when you
quot the Quran my scripture about Jesus
okay you qu the verse when Allah caus
him to sleep or for the sake of argument
raise him up to himself okay caus him to
die and raise him up do you believe in
that wait do you believe in that passage
that he caus him to sleep and raise him
up no I don't so why you using it then
you mean where am I using I'm asking you
a question about it no so no no no
you're not asking question
you my no my question you say Jesus died
or something yes I'm I'm asking was it
either past tense or was it a future
event but do mean you believe in it so
I'm going to ask you a question about
Mark 13:32 Mark 13:32 it says only the
father knows the hour so then there that
mean that you believe that he's the
father I don't believe he's the father
but I'm asking you that you believe in
the father so the question follow up is
Jesus the father or the son he says I
and the father are one no so he's a
father he say I and a father are one
they they have different know name I
can't I can't I I can't fully explain
the the different the different works
that they do right but is he wait so do
you believe that he's a son because
remember in John chap digressing again
I'm not digressing bro the father or not
cuz he's not the physical father so so
he's not father he's not the physical
father the
physical spiritual he's a spiritual
father the spiritual father yes so when
Jesus was getting crucified that was the
spiritual father getting crucified when
Jesus was getting crucified was that you
believe when Jesus was getting crucified
show me in the body show me in the Bible
said the father was getting crucified
show you in the Bible where the father
was getting crucified show me in the
Bible said the speech Spirit of the
father was getting crucified it does it
say
that you're adding it no Christian no
Christians believe that he's you know
what he's trying to do doing actually
it's called mental gymnastics he's doing
heretic according to
both the Christians the heretic no
Christians believe that the father Jes
in Jesus no they believe Jesus was God
and a man same time the spirit of God is
the son the father so this man is blew
his Spirit into Mary who spirit is it do
you believe that who spirit is it
believe I believe that Arabic let me let
me Arabic language believe that in
Arabic language when Allah Allah has no
you know do you ask me a question I'm
going to ask you in Arabic language
Allah attribute something to himself and
that thing exists independently he
attribute out of Honor for example Allah
said doesn't mean Allah's house is part
of Allah Allah to show to honor the
place to honor the house he attribute
the house to himself likewise Allah said
he the messenger of Allah means he's a
man that Allah
chosen I stop because another way is but
you you you accused you accused that the
woman what she was doing is Christianity
anyway so so let's go back to the point
the point is there's no Christians Hey
listen Soo yes sir is the father you
know the Father the father Spirit the
father of Jesus yeah the father of Jesus
Spirit the Father and Jesus same no no
no no say different
person
father when
Jesus it's false it's not it's not it's
not the spirit was inside Jesus
crucified no
no
yeah that was done are you really are
you really are you really
fine I don't mind a big manine
[Music]